in the last video we kind of reasoned
our way towards finding the sum of the
factors of 27,000 what I want to do in
this video is really just revisit what
we did in the last video and see if we
can come up with a more generalized way
of finding the sum of the factors of a
number so the last video we started with
27,000 we figured out that its prime
factorization is 3 to the third times 2
to the third times 5 to the third or
because the 2 to switch the order is
here and we use that information say
well ok if this is the prime
factorization of 27,000 then any factor
then any factor so let's say that this
is some factor of 27,000 it has to be
the product of powers of 3 2 and 5 so
let me make that clear it has to be 3 2
something times 2 2 something else they
could be the same number times 5 2
something else and each of these X wise
and Z's have to be between 0 and 3 and
they could be equal to 0 or 3 an axiom
it can be clear they have to be integers
they have to be integers where these are
integers integers this notation kind of
here implies that you could be any
number there but they have to be
integers in between 0 and 3 including 0
and 3 and just to be clear we can just
generate arbitrary factors here we could
say okay let's pick 0 it could be 3 to
the 0 times 2 to the second power times
5 to the 1 this will be a factor of
27,000 you could figure out this is 1
times 4 times 5 this is equal to 20 and
you could just look you can just keep
taking different values of x y&z to get
all the factors so essentially you have
to go through all of the different
combinations here and add them up and
that's what we did in the last video and
to be able to think through that I drew
a little bit of a grid I started with
powers of 3 so 3 to the 0 let me write
it here so you start with 3 to the 0 3
to the 1 3 squared 3 to the third is 27
and then I had powers of 2 2 to the 0 2
to the first 2 squared 2 squared is 4
and then 2 to the third
is eight and here I was just looking for
I was just looking for the combinations
where we're looking at the powers of
three and two and we're multiplying it
times five to the zero so we're not even
looking at having a 5 as a factor yet of
all of these combinations and what we
did is we just took each of these
numbers and we multiplied them by each
other so we took so these would just be
a 1 a 3 a 9 and a 27 I just took 1 times
1 isn't 1 3 times 1 is 3 and then you
could go down this row 1 times 2 is 2 3
times 2 is 6 9 times 2 is 18 you could
just keep going 27 times 2 is 54 and you
could keep figuring out all of these but
the shortcut that we did in the last
video is we said look you don't have to
figure out all of those you could just
take this sum over here so whatever this
is so 1 plus 3 plus 9 plus 27 we figured
out in the last video it was 40 but what
that this is the sum for this first
column the second sum is just going to
be 2 times this number so let me make it
clear this is the same thing as 1 times
this the second column is going to be is
going to be 2 times 2 times this thing
right because each of each of these
terms are just being multiplied by 2 so
it's 2 times 1 plus 3 plus 9 plus 27 and
then the third column is going to be 4
times it's going to be 4 times this
business over here so 4 times let me
scroll over 4 times 1 plus 3 plus 9 plus
and then the 4th column will be 8 times
and then there'll be plus 8 times all of
that stuff 1 plus 3 plus 9 plus 27 in
the last video I added them up and got
40 but I'm keeping them this way on
purpose because this thing right here
what I just wrote and this is this is
essentially the sums of all of the
combinations where X is where our X or
our X's and Y's are between 0 & 3
integers between 0 & 3 including zeros
in 3 and Z is 0 because we're not
multiplying any of these by 5 so when
you we ignore the 5 the sum here and
this is exactly what we did in the last
video this is exactly equal to this is
exactly equal to
one plus three plus nine plus 27 times x
one plus two plus four plus eight if you
just take this term right here if you
just take this term right here and
distribute it onto each of these terms
and distribute it onto each of those
terms you will get this expression up
here so to find all of the combinations
of the powers of two and three with the
with not multiplying things by five you
literally just have to take the powers
of three up to the third power because
that's how how many powers that's how
high we get when we do the prime
factorization of twenty-seven thousand
and sum them up and then multiply that
times the power of two up to the third
power and then what we did in the last
video we figured out okay this value
right here this is when we this is when
we're only dealing it with five to the
zero power if we want all of the
combinations we would want this grid
multiplied by five to the zero which is
essentially what this grid already is
and we would want to add that to that
grid multiplied by five to the first and
then add that to this grid multiplied by
five squared and then multiplied and
then and then add that to this whole
grid multiplied by five to the third and
so this whole grid the sum of this whole
grid is this right over here let's just
call this I don't know for simplicity
let's just call this a so if you really
want this the sum of all of the factors
of 27,000 you would take a and multiply
it by 5 to the 0 which is 1 and then add
that to a multiplied by 5 squared or
sorry multiplied by 5 to the 1st which
is 5 and then add that to a multiplied
by 5 squared which is 25 and then add
that and then add that to a multiplied
by 5 to the 3rd which is 125 and of
course you can factor out an a here so
this is our total sum this would be the
sum of all of the factors of 27,000 you
could factor an a out here and so our
sum would be a times 1 plus 5 plus 25
plus 125 and we know what a is a is this
thing over here so the sum of all of the
factors of 27,000 actually let me keep
this over here is equal to and I'll
color code it it's
equal to this this is a so a is 1 plus 3
plus 9 plus 27 it's not the right shade
of green but I hopefully you get the
point
times 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 times 1
plus 5 plus 25 plus 1 plus 125 so this
really just kind of sit this is
essentially is giving you a formula for
finding the sum of the factors of a
number you do the prime factorization of
the number and I'm not doing it in
general terms I'm doing it with a
particular case and I'm doing that
because I think it makes it a little bit
clearer why this works but our prime
factorization of 27,000 is 3 to the
third times 2 to the third times 5 to
the third if we really want to do the
sum and this is exactly what we did in
the last video I'm just expressing it
slightly different here we just take all
of the powers of 3 up to 3 to the 3rd
add them up all the powers of 2 up to 2
to the 3rd add them up all the powers of
5 up to 5 to the 3rd add them up and
then take the product and we can do that
right now so this is going to be so this
first term over here is this is 40 this
term right here 40 times this is 4 plus
8 is 12 plus 3 is 15 all right 3 up 15
and then times times 25 plus 125 is 150
so is 156 156 and if you take the
product here actually let's just do it
just to just to prove the point that
this actually does work so 40 times 15 4
times 15 is 60 so this is going to be
600 so this part right here is going to
be equal to 600 so it's going to boil
down to 600 times 156 so let's just do
that 156 well it's just multiplied it by
6 and then I'll add two zeros to it at
the end so 6 times 6 is 36 6 times 5 is
30 plus 3 is 33 6 times 1 is 6 plus 3 is
9 and of course if we want to multiply
it by 600 we just add two zeros here and
we get the exact same answer that we got
in the last video so hopefully you found
that useful I'm not I haven't proven it
in general terms but you can't maybe
I'll do that
I feel like doing a video on that but
you see a general a general method for
finding the sum of the factors of a
number actually let me just let me just
write that let's just do another problem
just to real fast let's say I had the
number I don't know let's say we had to
find the sum of the factors of the sum
of the factors of 300 so 300 is 3 times
100 which is 10 times 10 and that is 2
times 5 times 2 times 5 so 300 is equal
to 3 times 2 2 squared times 5 squared
that's the prime factorization of 300 so
if we wanted to find the sum of all of
its factors it would be 3 to the 0 3 to
the 0 which is 1 plus 3 to the 1 which
is 3 we won't go to any higher powers of
3 here because that's the highest power
we have in the prime factorization so
that's dealing with the threes times
times 2 to the 0 which is 1 plus 2 to
the 1 which is 2 plus 2 squared that's
how high we can get which is 4 and then
times and then times we just do the 5
times 5 to the 0 which is 1 plus 5 to
the first power which is 5 plus 5
squared which is 25 can't go any higher
than that because we only go up to two
fives up here 5 to the second power and
so this is going to be 4 times 7 4 times
7 times times 31 so this is going to be
28 times 31 28 times
31 1 times 28 is 28 but a 0 down here 3
times 8 is 24 3 times 2 is 6 plus 2 is 8
and then you get 8 6 & 8 so the sum of
all of the factors of 300 is 868
hopefully you found that interesting